it was a rainy morning we all went down
into our Sanctuary space I turned around
and there was the man with the gun
s they have an active shooter in the
building we've got a text that just said
active shooter at Tree of Life synagogue
Jerry and I looked at each other you
know Jerry's a doctor I'm a nurse and
but that somehow we could be helpful so
we moved in the direction of the gunfire
suspects talking about all these Jews
need to die
there's a great fear among people that
the culture of White America has been
diminished
these groups are emboldened they're
empowered and they're vocal the days
when synagogues just leave their doors
open
I think those days are gone
when you think about what can come of
this sort of situation you need to think
about the values for which the victims
stood
[Music]
whether two as a Catholic or Muslim
everybody's seemed touched because this
can happen to them
[Music]
because of misconceptions about both of
our communities a lot of people were
surprised to see the Muslim Community
step up and help the Jewish Community
our religions are very similar our
values are similar
[Music]
Parkland has been here the church in
Charleston they were here when there's a
shooting we text each other because
you'll just know what each other's
feeling it's about how we can change
other people's lives in a positive
manner because that is what the victims
would have wanted
their memories really are a blessing for
all of us
and part of them continues to live on
within us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alive